Speaker 1: Okay.
Dozens of you have asked me to address this
issue, and I'm ready to address it today.
I've been waiting for the story to develop
a little bit.
Some of you might remember this guy named
Jesse Lee Peterson.
Jesse Lee Peterson is sort of a prominent
black conservative.
He's a Christian pastor.
He has a men's counseling center in Los Angeles,
which I've been to when I was on Jesse's program
a couple of years ago.
His studio and his radio show all go out of
the same building, I believe it's called The
Bond in Los Angeles.
And it turns out it appears that the very
openly homophobic, anti-gay Christian pastor
Jesse Lee Peterson is gay.
And I'm going to talk about my experience
with him, which included him being pretty
handsy with me.
To be perfectly honest, I wasn't sexually
harassed.
I didn't feel intimidated or anything.
But at the time, I just wrote it off to this.
He this guy's just a character.
He's just pansy.
But I'm gonna get back to that.
Okay, so here's the story.
The Daily Beast now reporting allegations
of manosphere pastors, gay past royal macho
men.
Jesse Lee Peterson has emerged as one of the
right's most vocal anti-gay figures.
But his one time friends now allege that the
pastor has had many same sex relationships.
There are.
I'm not going to give you every claim, but
there are so many stories now of people saying,
I was involved in in sexual men saying I was
involved in sexual activity with Jesse Lee
Peterson.
He comes on to people aggressively in many
cases, etc..
Two of.
Two of Peter's.
Oh, hold on.
Let me go back.
Two of Peterson's former male associates came
out in June with on the record interviews
saying they engaged in sexual activities with
him.
Other men say he propositioned them.
These allegations about the pastor who is
publicly, staunchly heterosexual have ripped
like an earthquake through the manosphere,
prompting some Peterson allies to abandon
him and prompting one manosphere conference
to ban him altogether.
The Daily Beast was not able to substantiate
the allegations.
Petersen's Ministry, a Brotherhood organization
known as Bond, did not respond to multiple
requests for comment.
Okay, so what's my view on this?
I don't care about his sexuality, per se.
I really could not care less.
At this point, I just don't care about people's
sexual orientation.
It's boring to me.
I just don't care now.
Jesse Lee Peterson is definitely an odd guy.
He is seemingly obsessed with talking despite
being a black man, talking about how great
white people are and how terrible black people
are.
And he's also obsessed with talking about
how terrible and sinful and horrible it is
to be gay.
And he supposedly counsels young men out of
being gay, or at least that's what he claims
to do.
And it seems as though he is also gay himself.
Okay.
What I can tell you is that.
The vibe at his counseling office was really,
really weird.
So let me tell you what I personally observed.
Was he handsy at his office?
He was.
He kept you know, when we took pictures, he
was sort of like weirdly hugging me, arm around
me in a way that's like it's not it doesn't
raise any red flag.
I didn't think he was coming on to me.
I didn't feel intimidated or whatever.
There were people around, but it was just
like it was the first time I was meeting him
and he was a little bit handsy and I didn't
really think anything of it.
Now, in this context, maybe that was something
sort of different.
He was kind of like whispering into my ear,
like, not sweet nothings.
It was actually about Trump.
He was like, And I've said this before, like,
you're going to vote for Trump, aren't you,
David?
You're going to vote for Trump.
And I quite literally thought absolutely nothing
of it, like nothing at all, like what people
are describing the atmosphere at his office
with young men kind of hanging around the
fact that he counsels young men with Christian
counseling.
I did find it all weird, but not because I
thought it was a way for him to proposition
dudes, because it just seemed like this is
the last guy who should be counseling young
men.
And of course, he takes advantage of this
entire thing where, as many of you know to
say, one is a therapist, you actually need
a license.
You either need to be a psychologist or a
licensed social worker.
Licensed, independent social worker, psychiatrist,
licensed mental health counselor.
He was none of these things.
The term counselor or coach can be used by
anybody, any claim to be a counselor.
And of course, he's just a pastor.
He doesn't actually have any therapy credentials.
And that was the biggest red flag.
And there were all these young young men hanging
around and it was odd.
So is it a shock?
I mean, not really in the sense that we've
seen now dozens of the most openly and notably
homophobic Christian figures actually be gay
themselves.
In that sense, it's not really a shock.
It's only sort of surprising because this
is the only one that I personally know and
whose, you know, I went I was with him at
his office and all of these different things.
So that's really all I have to say about it.
It's not I mean, you know, it's not when people
started emailing me saying, David, it turns
out Jesse Lee Peterson is gay.
Okay.
No, I mean, that's my concern is more about
what are the the the lives that he has potentially
ruined.
Now, one other thing.
There was this interesting moment.
Jesse Lee Peterson is all about Alpha, the
alpha male.
And he says if you're on the left, your beta,
he's called me a beta male.
And we had an interview where I asked him,
are you like, are you in a relationship?
Are you are you sexually active or whatever?
And he said that he's off sex and he's off
sex because out of wedlock, I think was the
term he used.
You know, it's inappropriate or whatever.
But he seemed visibly uncomfortable with the
line of questioning.
And again, is it all related to this entire
hidden homosexuality thing that's going up?
Maybe.
I don't know.
You know, in retrospect, hindsight starts
to become clearer and clearer.
But I don't really know that any one of these
things is sort of like a big oh, it should
have been obvious that he was one of these
homophobic gay guys.
I can't I really can't say that.
I can only speak to my personal experience.
And that's what it is.
Very I mean, it's a sad story.
It's not sad that he's gay.
It's sad that he's gay and homophobic.
That's always sad when people can't just be
who they are.
And also that.
I have a very strange feeling about the entire
counseling of of young men.
Quite frankly, we're talking about boys in
many cases that he was doing.
And who knows what else we may learn about
this in
the future?
That's about it.